as to collusion conspiracy a conspiracy
not that I'm aware of so the decision
not to bring an indictment against the
president for conclusion conspiracy with
Russia has not changed no it hasn't
and the conclusion not to bring an
indictment against the president for
obstruction of justice has not changed
no I take it from your testimony that
the mummer team was unhappy when you
receive the letter from mr. mother I
can't speak to the team as a whole
all right certainly then when I talked
to Bob Muller he he he indicated he was
concerned about the press coverage that
had gone on the previous few days and he
felt that was to be remedied by putting
out more information okay I understood
you to say and these are my words not
yours the first concern that mr. Muller
had he felt like your letter wasn't
nuanced enough correct
okay that problems been solved as it not
was sort of solved by putting out the
whole report exact which was the that's
why I think this whole thing is sort of
mind-bendingly bizarre because I made
clear from the beginning that I was
putting at the report as much of the
report as I could and it was clear it
was gonna take three weeks or so maybe
four to do that and the question is
what's the placeholder and the
placeholder and my judgment was the
simple statement of what the bottom line
conclusions were and I wasn't going to
be in the business of feeding out more
and more information as time went on to
adjust to what the press was saying and
that's your call as Attorney General
absolutely okay that wouldn't be the
call of a US attorney or a special
counsel no not at all okay
now the second reason I mentioned the
nuance concern the second reason that
mr. Murrow was concerned I don't want to
say I'm happy because I don't I'm not
trying to be pejorative let's say
concern he was concerned about press
coverage
he indicated he felt that what was
inaccurate was the press coverage and
what they were interpreting the March
24th letter to say and what were you
supposed to do about that he wanted to
put out the full executive summaries
that are incorporated in the report and
I said to him I wasn't interested and
and by the way those summaries even when
he sent them apparently they actually
required later more redaction because of
the intelligence community so the fact
is we didn't have readily available
summaries that had been fully vetted but
I've made it clear to him I was not in
the business of putting out periodic
summaries because a summary would start
a whole public debate it's by definition
under-inclusive and I thought what we
should do is focus on getting the full
report out as quickly as possible which
we did and that's your call as attorney
Jim force of course and the news
coverage issue well none of us can
control what the news publishes a prince
except the media but but to the extent
that that argument was made they didn't
have the full report that that's a new
key issue to now isn't it yes okay can
you can you briefly go over with me one
more time what I find it curious that
the the mower team spent all this time
investigating obstruction of justice and
then reached no conclusion tell me again
briefly why mr. Muller told you he
reached no conclusion or he couldn't
make up his mind or whatever I'm not
trying to put words in your mouth I
really couldn't recapitulate it I it was
unclear to us we first discussed it on
March 5th the deputy was with me at
O'Callahan the principal associate
deputy and we we didn't really get a
clear understanding of the reasoning and
the report I'm not sure exactly what the
full line of reasoning is and that's one
of the reasons
I didn't want to try to put words in but
in the bottom others ma'am but he did
not choose to bring an indictment we
know that much right regardless of the
reason right I'm gonna repeat quickly in
less than one minute what we talked
about the last time you were here this
is one person's opinion
as I told you before I think
you
who decided in 2016 to act on their
political beliefs there were there were
two investigations here one was an
investigation of Donald Trump
there was another investigation of
Hillary Clinton I'd like to know how
that one started - and it would seem to
me that we all have a duty if not to the
American people to the FBI to find out
why these investigations were started
who started them and the evidence on
which they were started and I hope you
will do that and you get back we'll get
back to us and there's another short way
home here as well all you've got to do
is release the president can release all
the documents at the FBI and the Justice
Department pertaining to the 2016
election now you can redact national
security information but just release
them instead of us going through all
this spin and innuendo and leaks and
rumors let's just let the American
people see them and the final point I'll
make when you're investigating leaks at
the Department of Justice and the FBI I
hope you will include the Muller team as
well Thank You mr. chairman
Santa Clara charter Thank You mr.
chairman mr. turns general I'm going to
take us out of the weeds here because I
think the American people deserve to
know what happened in the election for
the highest office of the land and I'll
just give my views very quickly and not
ask you about these topics I think your
four-page letter was clearly a summary
and that's why director Muller called it
a summary I think when senator Van
Hollen and representative crisp asked
you if a special counsel disagreed with
you under oath you had to go out of your
way not to at least mention the fact
that he had sent you this letter but you
didn't mention it and then finally I
would say that we must hear from
director Muller because in response to
some of my colleagues questions you have
said that you didn't know what he meant
or why he said it and I believe we need
to hear from him so I want to first
start with Russia special counsel
Muller's report found that the russian
government interfered in the 2016
presidential election in a suite
and systematic fashion later director
Ray has informed us at twenty eighteen
was a dress rehearsal for the big show
in 2020 director coats the president's
intelligence advisor has told us that
the Russians are getting bolder yet for
the last two years Senator Lankford and
I on a bipartisan bill with support from
the ranking and the head of the
Intelligence Committee have been trying
to get the secure elections Act passed
this would require backup paper ballots
if anyone gets federal funding for an
election it would require audits and it
would require better cooperation yet the
white house just as we were on the verge
of getting a markup in the Rules
Committee getting it to the floor where
I think we would get the vast majority
of senators the white house made calls
to stop this were you aware of that No
okay well that happened so what I would
like to know from you as our nation's
chief law enforcement officer if you
will work with Senator Lankford and I to
get this bill done because otherwise we
are not going to have any clout to get
back up paper ballots if something goes
wrong in this election well I will I
will work with you to enhance the
security of our election and I'll take a
look at at what you're proposing I'm not
familiar with it okay well it is the
bipartisan bill it has been ur Burr and
Senator Warner it's support from Senator
Graham was on the bill senator Harris is
on the bill and the leads are senator
Langford and myself and it had
significant support in the house as well
the GRU the Russian military
intelligence agency targeted the u.s.
state and local agencies along with
private firms that are responsible for
electronic polling and voter
registration the GR us access voter
information and installed malware on a
voting technology companies Network I
understand the FBI will brief US senator
Rick Scott and Florida Governor De
Santis on efforts by Russian hackers to
gain access to Florida election data
will you commit to have the FBI provide
a briefing to all senators on this just
on the Florida situation on the entire
Russia situation
sure including the Florida situation
okay that will be helpful again senator
Lankford and I are trying to get our
bill passed and I think if everyone
hears about this
it may help also according to the report
the IRA purchased over 3500 ads on
Facebook to undermine our democracy as
the chairman has pointed out contrary to
what we heard from a high ranking
official at the White House this was not
just a few Facebook ads I am pleased
that chairman Graham has agreed to be
the lead Republican on the Honest ads
Act that I introduced last year with
Senator McCain and will you help us to
try at least to change our election laws
so that we can show where the money is
coming from and who's paying for these
ads so that people have access to these
ads in concept yes okay very good thank
you we need that support now let's go to
something I noted in your in the opening
you talked about how the two major
concerns at your nomination hearing were
about the report and about making the
report public there was a third concern
and it was something I raised and that
was your views on obstruction I asked
you if a president or any person
convincing a witness to change testimony
would be obstruction of justice and you
said yes the report found that Michael
Cohen's testimony to the house before it
that the president repeatedly implied
that Cohen's family members had
committed crimes do you consider that
evidence to be an attempt to convince a
witness to change testimony no I don't
think that that could could pass muster
those public statements he was making
could pass muster as sub or nation of
but this is a man in the highest office
in the most powerful job in our country
and he is basically I'm trying to think
how someone would react any of my
colleagues here if the president the
United States is implying getting out
there that your family members have
committed a crime so you don't consider
that any attempt to change testimony
well you you have
have two different things you have the
question of whether there's it's an
obstructive act and then also whether or
not it is a corrupt intent
I don't think general public statements
like that I have a well are we could
show that they would have a sufficiently
probable effect to constant okay well
then let's go to some private statements
the report found that the president's
personal counsel told Paul mana for that
he would be quote taken care of this is
in volume 2 page 123 224 that you don't
consider obstruction of justice
no not standing alone both for this on
both the same reasons and I think that
is my point here what you look at the
totality of the evidence that's what I
learned or when I was in law school you
look at the totality of the evidence in
the pattern here look at this the report
found that the president's personal
counsel told Michael Cohen that if he
stayed on message about the Trump Tower
Moscow project the president had his
back
that's volume 2 page 140 right but I
think the council acknowledged that it's
unclear whether he was reflecting the
president's statements on that the
report found that after mana 4 was
convicted the present and himself called
him a brave man for refusing to break
yes and that is not and that is not
obstruction because the president's
state the evidence I think what the
president's lawyers would say if this
were ever actually joined is that the
president's statements about flipping
are quite clear and expressed and and
uniformly the same which is by flipping
he meant succumbing to pressure on
unrelated cases to lie and compose in
order to get lenient treatment cases
that is not so discouraging flipping in
that sense is not obstruction okay well
look at the pattern here that the report
found that after Cohen's residents and
office were searched by the FBI the
president told Cohen to hang in there
and stay strong the port phone that
after National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn resigned
the president made public positive
it's about him and then when he
corroborated changed his tomb during
your confirmation hearing I asked you
whether a president deliberately
impairing the integrity or availability
of evidence would be obstruction and you
responded yes and this is a different
take on senator Feinstein's question
would causing McGann
the White House Council to create a
false record when the president asked
ordered him to have the when McGann he
told them to deny reports right he tells
him again
deny reports that the President ordered
him to have the council-fire if you
don't see that as as obstruction and
directing him to change testimony do you
think that would create a false record
to impair the integrity of evidence I
said there it fails on the the evidence
would not be sufficient to establish any
of the three elements there first it's
not sufficient to show a obstructive act
because it is unclear whether the
president knew that to be false in fact
the president's focus on the fact that I
never told you to fire again did I ever
say fire I never told you to fire Magan
Magan Magan I'm getting it something
it's about impairing the integrity of
the evidence I just see it as different
this is the second thing there's no it's
hard to establish the nexus to the
proceeding because he already had
testified to the to the Special Counsel
he'd given his evidence as the report
itself says there is evidence that the
president actually thought and believed
that the Times article was wrong
that's evidence on the president's side
of the ledger that he actually thought
it was wrong and was asking for its
correction it is also possible the
report says that the president's intent
was directed at at the publicity and the
press the government has to prove things
beyond a reasonable doubt and as the
report shows there's there's ample
evidence on the other side of the ledger
that would present prevent the
government from establishing that okay
again
I look at the totality of the evidence
and when you look at it it is a pattern
and that is different than having one
incident Thank You mr. chairman yes
ma'am sooner sis Thank You mr. chairman
general Barr I'd like to go back to to
Russia and your opening statement laid
out some of what the GRU had done what
military Russian military intelligence
had done in terms of hacking I'd also
like to look at some of the oligarchs
and some of the corruption so closely
aligned with Putin volume 1 pages 129 to
144 largely about Deripaska can you tell
us who he is and what his objectives are
I'd rather not get get into that in this
open setting well at least quote the
Department of Treasury because this is a
public document so Oleg Deripaska is a
designated individual he's possessed as
a Russian diplomatic passport he
regularly claims to represent the
Russian government
he's an aluminum and other metals
billionaire and he's been investigated
by the US government and by other of our
allies for money laundering he's been
accused of threatening the lives of his
business rivals he's been charged with
the illegal wiretapping taking part in
extortion and racketeering schemes
he's bribed government officials he's
ordered the murder of a businessman and
he has many links to Russian organized
crime so I think we can in an open
setting at least agree that he's a bad
dude right this is a this is a
bottom-feeding scum sucker and he has
absolutely no I'll take your laughes
agreement he has absolutely no alignment
with the interests of the u.s. people
and our public so the the section of
volume 1 that deals with nominally Paul
Manafort but is really about Deripaska I
would like you to help us have an
American public 101 understanding of
what is and isn't allowed
so Paul Manafort is hired by Deripaska
ostensibly for things related to the
Ukraine they have a bunch of failed
there's business ventures together it
looks like overtime but he's on the
payroll of a Russian oligarch that has
completely misaligned with the American
government and the American people and
with the interests of NATO and he's on
his payroll is it permissible for
someone to be paid by somebody who's
basically an enemy of the United States
and then could that individual just
volunteer and start to donate their time
and talent and expertise to a campaign
in the US and I mean this let me
interrupt for a second so one of the
things that I think is painfully tragic
about a hearing like this I think the
vast majority of the American people are
gonna tune it out and those that pay
attention are gonna think the only two
takeaways you need to know is a bunch of
people were Pro Trump before they came
and they stayed pro Trump but a bunch of
people were antitrump before they came
and they stayed antsy Trump and we
didn't dig into any of what the report
actually says I think these 448 pages
say a whole bunch of really important
things about intelligence operations
against the United States people and our
public and our government and our public
trust and I think it isn't just about
2016 they're important questions about
2016 Lindsey the Chairman Graham
summarized at the beginning how much
money and time was available to the
special counsel and his team to do their
work so there are a bunch of factual
matters about 2016 that matter but if
one of the most important things we take
away from this isn't that we're gonna be
it needs to be that we're going to be
under attack again in 2020 and it isn't
just gonna be Russia who's pretty dang
clunky at this stuff but it's also over
time likely gonna be China who's gonna
be much more sophisticated about this
stuff can you help us understand what is
legal and illegal about foreign
intelligence services being involved in
US elections and what should American
people and the American public and
especially American campaign operatives
know about what's appropriate not
appropriate to take in the form of help
from foreign intelligence agencies
I mean that's a that's a very broad
topic what is legal and illegal I think
it could you refine it a little bit
you're talking about what kind of what
kind of propaganda that kind of thing
coming into the country kid could you
make it money into into a foreign money
obviously into a campaign yeah but could
you take could Russia China I'm making
up a country decide to come into the
United States and look at all the
political talent make a database by the
way the OPM hack in 2014 tells us the
Chinese government is actively involved
in creating databases of people they can
potentially use as leverage against
American citizens more than 20 million
people are already in the spy
recruitment database of the China of the
Communist Party of China could they come
in and build a database of all campaign
operatives in the US and some foreign
entity just decide to hire all of them
and then say why don't you go and
volunteer for this campaign and you go
and volunteer for that campaign
could we have campaign Chairman and
women running around the u.s. US
citizens who have u.s. campaign talent
and experience paid for by foreign
entities just choosing to volunteer on
campaigns going forward is that legal if
they're if their time is paid for for
the purpose of participating in a
campaign I wouldn't think it's legal but
given how sleazy so much of this city is
and a whole bunch of people live on
retainers of 15 and 20 and $30,000 a
month
is it always obvious what you're paid
for versus what you do so some Russian
oligarch just decides to start putting
American campaign personnel on retainer
payments and say we may need you to
lobby for something somewhere in the
future they've got views about oil
pipelines and natural gas pipelines into
Germany we just hold you on retainer and
by the way the fact that you're a person
who likes to work for specific campaigns
and certain parties and causes feel free
to go and all vocationally do whatever
the heck you want whenever you want is
that is that a place we should head is
that is that allowed under US law today
well I mean it depends on on the
specific circumstances the nature of the
agreement what the what the who the
person is representing are they
representing the interests of a foreign
government or they a foreign agent who
are they registered you know I mean we
could
it's a slippery area and we could sit
here all day and and without specific I
only have seven minutes I don't I don't
get all day but you're the chief law
enforcement officer of the United States
government and I think it would be
helpful for us to have a shared
understanding as we head toward the 2020
election of what campaign operatives
should well understand is beyond the
pale so if if the Chinese government
decides to start hacking into 2020
campaigns
I would hope there's clarity from the
Department of Justice about whether or
not Democratic campaign presidential
campaigns and whether or not the Trump
reelection campaign are allowed to say
hey we're interested in this hacked
material going forward I think we need
to have clarity about a question like
that and I think as somebody who sits
not just on judiciary but on the
Intelligence Committee I think there are
a bunch of counterintelligence
investigations happening right now in
the United States where campaigns don't
really understand what the laws are and
I think we need a lot more clarity about
it because I'm nearly at time let me at
least give it to you as a this version
as a precise question under the
presidential transitions Act once you
have a Democratic nominee for president
and a Republican nominee for president
one of the things that we do is we start
to brief them on in the event that you
would become the presidental Act you
will need to know where we are in
different national security issues
should we be adding to the presidential
transition Act counterintelligence
briefings for campaigns as they become
the nominee in a much more detailed way
than the response you had about the
bureau's efforts when Senator Cornyn
asked if defensive briefings were given
should we the Congress be thinking very
intensely about authorizing the ability
of the bureau and in a shared broader
icy context but with the bureau or
Homeland Security probably being the
interface entity should nominees for the
highest office in the land
heading into 2020 be receiving regular
counterintelligence briefings on the
fact that foreign intelligence services
are going to surround people that are
likely going to be people of influence
and principal officers of the United
States government should they win
absolutely I think the the danger from
countries like China Russia and so forth
is far more insidious than it has been
in the past because of nontraditional
collectors that they have operating in
the United States
and I think most people are unaware of
how pervasive it is and how and what the
risk level is and I think it actually
should go far beyond even campaigns more
people involved in government have to be
educated
thank you I'm at time but I would love
to work with you in the broader
intelligence community on that more I
think there are a number of members of
the sissie of the Senate Intelligence
Committee who know what you're saying
particularly about the Chinese
government and their attempt to encircle
lots of people who are going to have
influence in the future and I think we
not just a whole-of-government effort
but as a whole of society effort have to
become much more sophisticated about
what foreign intelligence services and
especially the Chinese are plotting for
the future yeah if I could just say that
you know the pattern is whenever there
is an election foreign governments and
their operatives frequently descend on
the people who they think could have a
shot at winning and it's it's common and
and took the most typical scenario is
that they do try to make contacts and so
forth and in a digital cyber era you
don't need a bar and a hooker anymore
you can surround people digitally much
easier and we know that we're gonna be
having these kinds of attacks in the
future and we need to up our game Thanks
- the bar and the hooker will have
hearings about all this stuff
Sarah Coons Thank You chairman Graham
thank you Attorney General Barr and I
want to follow up on some of that line
of questioning from Senator sass and
clover sure the Special Counsel was
appointed first to investigate Russia's
attack on her 2016 election and
potential coordination with the Trump
campaign and I'm glad the chairman I'm
started this hearing by recognizing we
need to focus on that demonstrable
assault on our democracy and to protect
our elections going forward and I look
forward to working with my colleagues
whether it's on sanctions bills or it's
on the Lankford Klobuchar bill but we
genuinely need leadership from you mr.
Attorney General and from the White
House and our president to make sure
that we are doing everything we can to
protect our next election but frankly we
also can't ignore volume two of this
report which I think details
unacceptable conduct by the president
and his kin
and that includes trying to fire the
special counsel without cause I
appreciated the leadership of senators
Graham and tell us a Booker and I in a
bill to try and protect the special
counsel something I think is still worth
doing for future special counsels we
were told by many of our colleagues
there was nothing to worry about because
the president wasn't going to fire the
special counsel but I was particularly
struck by some reports in the second
volume that the president attempted to
do exactly that
and I frankly mr. Attorney General have
concerns that your March 24 letter
obscured that conduct and as a result
work to protect the president for
several weeks rather than give the full
truth to the American people as I now
believe special counsel Muller was
urging you to do as reflected in the
letter we just received today so I'm
going to ask you some questions about
the report but the bottom line is that I
think we need to hear more about the
special counsels work from the special
counsel according to special counsel
Muller's report in June of 2017
President Trump called White House
Counsel magan and directed him to have
the special counsel removed and I quote
this is from about page 85 86 McGann
recalled the president called him at
home twice and on both occasions
directed him to call Rosen Stein and say
that Muller had conflicts and could no
longer serve as special counsel there
were no credible conflicts began
testified that he had shared that these
conflicts were silly were not real and
Chris Christie advised President Trump
about the same time there were no
substantive basis no good cause to fire
the special counsel in one call the
president said coal rod tell rod Muller
has conflicts can't be the special
counsel quote Muller has to go and I
assume he didn't mean go to Cleveland or
go to Seattle he meant go be fired call
me back when you do it I think the
president's demands to fire Muller
without cause are alarming and
unacceptable and mr. Attorney General
not one bit of what I just described was
in your March 24th letter to this
committee wasn't no but if I wasn't but
it was in the summaries that were
offered to you by special counsel Muller
and his team which you chose not to
release is that correct
they were they were in the fight they
were in complete form in the final
report which I was striving to make
public in which I did make public
which I respect and appreciate but a
critical three weeks passed between when
you delivered the letter with the focus
on the principal conclusions and when we
ultimately got the redacted report and
what I take from the Malheur letter why
were they critical well I think that the
volume to summary would have revealed to
the general public a whole range of
inappropriate actions by the president
his core team I'll go to a second
episode that I think is important on
February 5th of 2018 over a week after
the story broke publicly that the
President ordered his White House
Council to fire the Special Counsel
investigating the president the
president demanded that McGann create a
false record saying the president never
directed McGann to fire the special
counsel the president wasn't looking for
a press statement here he wasn't looking
to correct the record he wanted a
fraudulent record for White House
Records a letter that wasn't true McGann
refused to do it again there's nothing
about the President's request to create
a false record in your March 24th letter
is there well that's your
characterization of it and I've been
through it a couple of times and I and I
think it would be difficult for the
government to prove that beyond a
reasonable doubt and an important thing
there is there are very plausible
alternative explanations but the what I
was trying to get out was the final
report and and have one issuance of the
complete report I made it clear in the
March 24th letter that Bob Miller didn't
make a decision but that he felt he
could not exonerate the president that's
right I wasn't hiding the ball on where
Muller was and that he was presenting
both sides of the issue all the evidence
but he was not making a call but he felt
he couldn't exonerate the president and
then I briefly described the process we
went through to make a judgement
internal into the Department of Justice
and as I say from the public interest
standpoint I felt there should be only
one thing issued
should be the complete report as
complete as it could be and I know we
differ in our conclusions about what
that meant but my concern is that that
gave president Trump and his folks more
than three weeks of an open field to say
I was completely exonerated when had you
released the summaries of it the first
and second volume we would have been
more motivated than ever
based on the first volume to work
cooperatively to protect our next
election and more concern than ever
about misdeeds about inappropriate
actions by the President and by some of
his core team as a result of the summary
of the second volume and at the end of
the day you've had a number of exchanges
with colleagues who've said I can't tell
you why Muller chose not to charge I
want to hear that from Bob Muller I
think we should hear from special
counsel Muller let me move on to a point
that Senator sass was just asking but
that I think is worth revisiting about
foreign intelligence and their role in
our elections the reason we had this
investigation the first place was George
papadopolis was told the Russians had
dirt on Hillary Clinton the Russians had
a direct contact to Donald Trump jr. and
offered to give a dirt about his
father's opponent Donald Trump jr. said
I loved it and invited the campaign
chairman and president's son-in-law to
the campaign chairman to a meeting with
her to get it who did you say offered it
who did you say offered it in the second
instance it was Russians made an offer
to Donald Trump I have 30 seconds okay
let me get to a question if I could
going forward what if a foreign
adversary let's now say North Korea
offers a presidential candidate dirt on
a competitor in 2020 do you agree with
me the campaign should immediately
contact the FBI if a foreign
intelligence service or a representative
of foreign government says we have dirt
on your opponent should they say I love
it let's meet in contact the FBI are an
intelligence service does yes okay
here's my core concern the president
ordered the White House Council to have
special counsel Muller fired he
fabricated evidence to cover it up and
whether or not you could make a criminal
charge of this it is unacceptable and
everyone who said we didn't have to
worry
President Trump firing the special
counsel was flat-out wrong
the Russians offered the Trump campaign
dirt on Hillary Clinton and the Trump
campaign never reported that to the FBI
instead they tried to conceal the
meeting and mislead the American people
and I think we have to work on a
bipartisan basis going forward to
protect our elections from a repeat of
this and we need your leadership and the
president's you somehow concluded the
president didn't obstruct justice and
you announced that you had cleared the
president 25 days before the public
could read the Muller report for
themselves I think it's no wonder
Special Counsel Muller thought your
four-page letter created public
confusion about critical aspects of the
results of the investigation and that
that threatened to undermine the central
purpose for which he was appointed I
think we need to hear from special
counsel Muller I think we need to hear
from Don McGann and I think we need to
review how we are going to handle going
forward the fact that you are
supervising 12 ongoing cases that came
out of the Muller investigation and have
been referred this body has a central
role in oversight that I believe we need
to exercise and given your recent record
Thank You mr. chairman yeah sooner Holly
Thank You mr. chairman
general Bart I come into your candor in
calling what happened in 2016 what it is
which is spying the Trump campaign
and spying on the president United
States let's talk a little bit more
about spying counterintelligence
investigations like the one that we now
know the FBI launched against Canada
Trump and President Trump
those are designed to thwart spying and
sabotage is that correct that's correct
to your knowledge has the FBI ever
launched a counterintelligence
investigation of another president that
you're aware of not to my knowledge it's
so it's safe to say that to your
knowledge this move was completely
unprecedented
to my knowledge would it be unusual in
your experience into your knowledge for
FBI agents to hide the existence and
results of an investigation such an
investigation from their superiors did
you say it would it be typically no no
would it be unusual yes and in fact that
is that is indeed what press reports
suggest
happened here when FBI officials hide
investigators investigations from
superiors is there anybody to hold them
accountable I mean what happens in that
instance there is no accountability have
you looked into the decision by the FBI
into why have they launched a counter
intelligence investigation I am looking
into it and I have looked into it and
you will will you commit to to telling
us what you find is the result of your
of your own review and investigation
well at the end of the day when I form
conclusions I intend to share it I'll
take that as a yes let me ask you about
the twenty-fifth amendment if I might
for just a moment
we know that former acting director of
the FBI Andy McCabe he's publicly
confirmed that he contemplated forcing
the president from awesome office using
the 25th amendment to your knowledge
have FBI officials ever contemplated
forcing any other president from office
against his will using that provision
not to my knowledge
the 25th amendment contemplates the vice
president taking over as president and
when the president is unable to act
would you agree that that text
contemplates physical ailments like a
coma mental incapacitation not just
political differences of opinion yes
have you ever doubted since you have
been in your current position whether
this president is physically able in a
constitutional sense to discharge the
duties his duties as president no would
you agree that discussions within the
FBI of forcing the president out of
office for political reasons gives the
public at best reason to question what
the FBI is doing in to fear that there
may be abuses of power in that
organization I think it gives reason to
be concerned about those particular
individuals that were involved I don't
attribute it to the organization
speaking of particular individuals who
involved I have to say I've listened to
this testimony all day today and to me
maybe the most shocking thing I've heard
is this chairman read it earlier August
26th 2016 this is a text message from
Peter struck a top counterintelligence
investigator who we now know helped
launch this CounterSpy investigation of
the President of the United States Peter
struck says just went to a southern
virgin
a Walmart I could smell the Trump
support smell is capitalized just went
to a Southern Virginia Walmart I could
smell the Trump support my view you want
to know what's really going on here you
want to know why the counterintelligence
investigation really happened you want
to know why we're all really sitting
here today that's why right there is
because an unelected bureaucrat an
unelected official in this government
who clearly has open disdain if not
outright hatred for Trump voters like
the people of my state for instance I
could smell the Trump support then tried
to overturn the results of a democratic
election that's what's really gone on
here that's the story that's why we're
here today I cannot believe that a top
official of this government with the
kind of power that these people had
would try to exercise their own
prejudices and that's what this is it's
open blatant prejudice would try to use
that in order to overturn a democratic
election and to my mind that's the real
crisis here and it is a crisis because
if there's not accountability if this
can go on in the United States of
America then my goodness gracious we
don't have a democracy anymore so I
appreciate your leadership mr. Attorney
General
I look forward to hearing the results of
your investigation and I look forward to
this committee continuing its
constitutional responsibility to find
out what is going on here and making
sure that the will of the people is
vindicated and established Thank You mr.
chairman
Blumenthal Thank You mr. chairman
Thank You Attorney Joe bar for being
here today
you've been very adroit and agile and
your responses to questions here but I
think history will judge you harshly and
maybe a bit unfairly because you seem to
have been the designated fall guy for
this report and I think that conclusion
is inescapable in light of the four-page
summary and then the press conference
you did on the day it was released
knowing that you had in hand a letter
from this
for council saying that he felt that you
mischaracterize his report and you were
asked by one of my colleagues senator
Van Hollen what do you know whether you
knew that Bob Miller supported your
conclusion and you said I don't know
whether Bob Miller supported my
conclusion you were asked by
representative Chris excuse me senator
that conclusion was not related to my
description of the findings in the March
24th letter I that conclusion refers to
my conclusion on the obstruction well
cases so it's it's a different different
include inclusions that was used by
Special Counsel Muller and on the
obstruction issue at page 8 and 182 of
the report I don't know whether you have
it in front of you the special counsel
specifically said at the same time I'm
quoting if we had confidence after a
thorough investigation of the facts that
the president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
he said it again at page 182 and yet in
your summary and in the press room
conference that you did you in effect
cleared the President on both so-called
clear and the difference difference is I
use the proper standard that statement
you just read is actually a very strange
statement for a part of the specific
obstruction episodes robert muller
concluded that there was substantial
evidence on four on the three necessary
elements of obstruction well you're on
your a project I don't have to finish my
quest
you haven't let me finish my answer well
let me just finish we can do both you
ignored in that press conference and in
the summary that Robert MOA found
substantial evidence and it's in the
report and we have a chart that shows
the elements of that crime intent
interference with an ongoing
investigation and the obstructive act so
I think that your credibility is
undermined within the department in this
committee and with the American people
and I want to ask you whether on those
remaining investigations the 12 to 14
investigations whether you have had any
communication with anyone in the White
House know and will you give us an
ironclad commitment that you will in no
way I'm not sure you know the laundry
list of investigations but I certainly
haven't talked the substance or been
directed to do anything on any of the
case well let me give you an opportunity
to clarify have you had any
conversations with anyone in the White
House about those ongoing investigations
that were spawned or spun off by I don't
I don't recall having any discuss
absentia discussion on the investigate
have you had any non substantive
discussion yeah it's possible that the
name of a case was mentioned and have
you provided information about any of
those ongoing investigate any invested
any information whatsoever
I don't recall no you don't recall I
don't recall providing any wouldn't you
recall about whether you gave
information to somebody in the White
House about an ongoing criminal
investigation in the Southern District
of New York or the Eastern District New
York or
the Eastern District of Virginia or them
Department of Justice yeah I mean I I
just don't recall providing any
substantive information about a case is
there anything that would refresh your
recollection if I probably looked over a
list of cases and thought about it but
but I don't recall just know what those
investigations are we've discussed them
at your confirmation hearing correct
whether I think you're 12 or 18 cases
right you don't know what those
investigations are mr. I do generally
but I you know I can't remember each
okay let me ask you one last time
you can't recall whether you have
discussed those cases with anyone in the
White House including the present United
States my recollection is I have not
discussed those that you don't recall
for sure I did let me move I I could I
can say very surely I did not discuss
the substance of it will you recuse
yourself from those investigations no
let me ask you about a couple of quotes
from the president since a number of my
colleagues have raised the Russian
investigation and these are from the
report untruths recited by the report
from the president in December of 2016
when President Trump was asked about the
intelligence community's conclusion that
Russia interfered in our election to
boost Trump's chances he said he had
quote no idea if it's Russia China or
somebody it could be somebody sitting in
a bed someplace four hundred one person
I'm sorry mr. chairman four hundred
pound person sitting on a bit that isn't
what the president said he referred to
it as somebody he also at Helsinki
denied Russian attacks in 2016 on our
election another lie two days after
President Trump was elected Russian
officials told the press that the
Russian government had maintained
contact
with Trump's quote immediate entourage
end quote during the campaign when
President Trump was asked about it he
said quote there was no communication
between the campaign and any foreign
entity during the campaign that's at
page 21 of volume 2 the first quote I
gave you was from page 21 of volume 2
the president initially denied playing
any role in shaping his son's statement
to the press about the now infamous June
9th meeting the mother report
established that the president dictated
a misleading statement about that
meeting through his communications
director ho pix that's at page 101 and
102 a volume 2 after news organizations
reported that the President ordered
McGann mr. McGann to have the special
counsel removed the president publicly
disputed these accounts the Mulla report
establishes that quote substantial
evidence supports the conclusion that
the president in fact directed began to
call Rosenstein to have the special
counsel removed
that's a volume 2 page 88 in your view
did President Trump on those occasions
and others recited in the report lie to
the American people well I'm not in the
business of determining when lies are
told to the American people I mean the
business of determining whether a crime
has been committed so he may have lied
but but I'd like an opportunity to
answer some of these questions okay you
started by you started by by citing this
thing in volume 2 about how the report
says that they could not be sure that
they could clearly say that he did not
violate the law as you know that's not
the standard we use in the criminal
justice system it's presumed that
someone is innocent and the government
has to has to prove that they clearly
violated the law we're not in the
business of exoneration we're not in the
business of proving they didn't violate
them I found that wholly Donner rated
him in your press conference and
your four-page skews memory how did that
start I didn't hear the beginning of the
question
you in fact exonerated or cleared the
press no I didn't exonerate I I said
that we did not believe that there was
sufficient evidence to establish an
obstruction offense which is the job of
the Justice Department and the job of
the Justice Department is now over that
determines whether or not there's a
crime the report is now in the hands of
the American people everyone can decide
for themselves there's an election in 18
months that's very democratic process
but we're out of it we have to stop
using the criminal justice process as a
political weapon my time has expired I
apologize mr. chairman but I would just
say that the four-page letter and the
press conference that you did left the
clear impression and it's been repeated
again and again that you cleared the
president thank thank you sir
Thank You mr. chair and thank you
attorney general bar for being here
today and visiting with all of us the
special counsels investigation and and
all of the ripples that came from the
2016 presidential election have really
permeated the country I mean there's
great interest in this and as I'm
touring the the 99 counties of Iowa I am
asked about this at town halls and other
interactions with my constituents just
as much as any other issue at hand and
I'm sure many of the other senators here
have had the same experience and I'd
like to start today by visiting with you
about the actions of Russia during the
2016 presidential election I think
that's where a lot of us would like to
see the focus go we need to focus on
what happened in the 2016 election and
then look ahead and make sure we are
safeguarding our practices so I think
it's natural to think of acts of
aggression by a foreign state in terms
of bullets terms of bombs that's what we
typically thought of is acts of
aggression
after all up and
just recent days acts of aggression or
warfare has been a symmetrical operation
by a foreign adversary in the past has
been practiced by boots on the ground or
various bombing campaigns but that's not
what we are facing today and I do
believe what we saw from Russia was an
act of aggression other adversarial
foreign States not just Russia but I
think number of colleagues have
mentioned China as well perhaps North
Korea Iran we could go on and on not
only do they practice direct hostile
military action just as Russia dead in
Ukraine with its illegal annexation of
Crimea but as was detailed in the
special counsels report they seek to
influence the elections of our free
states through cyber means and it is an
objective fact that Russia attempted to
influence our election we know that
folks all of us admit to that we see the
evidence that Russia tried to influence
our election the hacks the
disinformation and social media cyber
attacks by Russia were done with the
intent to sow discord among the American
people
Russia will show no hesitation they have
not in the past they won't in the future
and using these types of acts of
aggression in an attempt to undermine
our elections process and our way of
life and it doesn't matter if the attack
is coming from the end of a barrel of a
gun or the click of a mouse
we have to get to the bottom of it and
so general Barr the past two years we've
been talking about this investigation in
terms of what happened and now we have
the opportunity to decide how to do
better so the special counsels report is
the end of the road I think many have
stated that the end of the road when it
comes to the question of the Trump
administration's intent but it is just
the beginning of the conversation on how
we counter Russia and other foreign
adversaries in their attempts to
undermine our Republic
so if we can talk about
that 2016 presidential election do you
see vulnerabilities or weaknesses that
existed at that time that left us open
to foreign aggression for an influence
in the election system and then how do
we move forward through the Department
of Justice and making sure we're shoring
up some of those avenues of approach of
our foreign adversaries yes the FBI you
know has a very robust program the
foreign influence task force which is
focused on this problem and is working
to counteract and prepare for the kinds
of interference that we sort have seen
and it's a very dynamic program I've
been briefed on it by by Chris Rea and
I'm very impressed with what they're
what they're up to I think that the way
I the way I view this general problem is
there has always been efforts by Russia
and other hostile countries to influence
American elections and public opinion
but it was more easily detectable and it
was sort of a cruder operation in the
past and what we have now is with
technology and the democratization of
information the danger is far more
insidious and it it enables not only
them getting into effectively our whole
communication system here in the United
States and I'm just I mean just the way
we communicate with each other and and
into our business systems our
infrastructure but it also allows them
to do exactly what we've seen which is
because of our robust First Amendment
freedoms they're able to come in and
pretend they're Americans and and effect
the dialogue and and the social dynamics
in the United States in a way that
they've never been able to do before
and it's a huge challenge to deal with
it but I think the intelligence
community is responding to the challenge
and the
I think I had this discussion with Bob
Muller on on March 5th when he was
briefing me on his work and discussing
lessons learned what he has seen in
dismantling the threats that he's you
know was able to detect and how we can
start using that approach across the
board so I see we've accomplished a lot
through our federal agencies and through
the Department of Justice then are we
able to work with different social media
giants other private organizations to
help counter some of this do you see
that they are actually stepping up to
this challenge taking this on and making
sure that they are pushing back as well
against what they might determine is a
foreign adversary yes I think the the
private companies are us you know
stepping up their game and being more
responsible and addressing it I think I
think that's important I'm sorry I just
think it's important that we really
focus on why we're here today and that's
because we did see Russian influence in
our 2016 presidential election well we
need to make sure as many of our other
colleagues have have noted is that this
doesn't happen to us again and that we
are aware and as a public we are aware
of what has been happening not just in
our own elections process here in the
United States but to many of our allies
around the globe as well and making sure
that we are adequately pushing back
against that and and even overmatching
in making sure that that we keep that
type of influence out of our election
cycle so I appreciate your time today
thank you very much general aren't you
senator Hirono Thank You mr. chairman
mr. Barr now the American people know
that you are no different from Rudy
Giuliani or Kellyanne Conway or any of
the other people who sacrificed their
once decent reputation for the grifter
and liar who sits in the Oval Office you
once turned down a job offer from Donald
Trump to represent him as his private
attorney and your confirmation hearing
you told senator Feinstein that quote
the job
attorney general is not the same as
representing and quote the president so
you know the difference but you've
chosen to be the president's lawyer and
side with him over the interests of the
American people to start with you should
never have been involved in supervising
the robert muller investigation you
wrote a 19 page unsolicited memo which
you admit was not based on any facts
attacking the premise of half of the
investigation and you also should have
insisted that deputy attorney general
rob rosenberger here isn't just a
witness to some of the president's
obstructive behavior we now know he was
in frequent personal contact with the
president a subject of the investigation
you should have left it to career
officials then once the report was
delivered by the special counsel you
delayed its release for more than two
weeks you let the president's personal
lawyers look at it before he even
deigned to let Congress where the public
see it during the time you substituted
your own political judgment for the
special counsels counsels legal
conclusions in a four-page letter to
Congress and now we know thanks to a
free press that mr. Mulder wrote your
letter objecting to your so-called
summary when you called Muller to
discuss his letter the reports are that
he thought your summary was giving the
press Congress and the public a
misleading impression of his work he
asked you to release the report
summaries to correct the misimpression
you created but you refused when you
finally did decide to release the report
over a congressional recess and on the
eve of two major religious holidays you
called a press conference to once again
try to clear Donald Trump before anyone
had a chance to read the special
counsels report and come to their own
conclusions but when we read the report
we knew Robert Miller's concerns were
valid and that your version of events
was false you used every advantage of
your office to create the impression
that the president was cleared of
misconduct you selectively quoted
fragments from the special counsels
report taking some of the most important
statements out of context and ignoring
the rest
you put the power and authority of the
office of their Attorney General and the
Department of Justice behind a public
relations effort to help Donald Trump
protect himself
finally you lied to Congress youto
Representative charlie Crist's that you
didn't know what objections Muller's
team might have to your March 24th
so-called summary you told senator chris
van hollen that you didn't know if Bob
Muller supported your conclusions but
you knew you lied and now we know a lot
of respected nonpartisan legal experts
and elected officials were surprised by
your efforts to protect the president
but I wasn't surprised you did exactly
what I thought you'd do is why I voted
against your confirmation I expected you
would try to protect the president and
indeed you did in 1989 this isn't there
something you hadn't done before in 1989
when you refused to show Congress and
OLC opinion that led to the arrest of
Manuel Noriega in 1992 when you
recommended pardons for the subjects of
the iran-contra scandal and last year
when you wrote the 19 page memo telling
Donald Trump as president can't be
guilty of obstruction of justice and
then didn't recuse yourself from the
matter from the beginning you were
addressing an audience of one that
person being Donald Trump that's why
before the bombshell news of yesterday
evening eleven of my Senate colleagues
and I called on the Department of
Justice Inspector General and Office of
Professional Responsibility to
investigate the way you have handled the
Mullen report I wanted them to determine
whether your actions and complied with
the department's policies and practices
and whether you have demonstrated
sufficient impartiality to continue to
oversee the fourteen other criminal
matters that the special counsel
referred to in other parts to other
parts of the Department of Justice but
now we know more about your deep
involvement and trying to cover up for
Donald Trump being Attorney General of
the United States is a sacred trust you
have betrayed
trust America deserves better you should
resign I have some questions for you is
the White House exerting any influence
on your decision whether to allow
special counsel Muller to testify in
Congress and when no now you've been
clear today that you don't think that
any of the 10 episodes of possible
obstruction that's a special counsel
outlined is a crime I disagree but you
seem to think that if it's not a crime
then there's no problem
nothing to see here nothing to worry
about so with apologies to Adam Schiff
do you think all of the things that
President Trump did are okay are they
what the President of the United States
should be doing for example do you think
it's okay for a president to fire an FBI
director to stop him from investigating
links between his campaign and Russia it
may not be a crime but do you think it's
okay well I think the report is clear
that no I'm not talking about the report
whether I'm occurred I'm asking you you
think it's okay for the president to do
what he did to fire the Special Counsel
I think it to keep them from what he did
and I don't think the evidence supports
the proposition I guess you're stopped
the investigation do you think it's okay
for a president to ask his White House
Counsel to lie well I'm willing to talk
about what's criminal no we've already
acknowledged that you think it was not a
crime I'm just asking whether you think
it's okay even if it's not a crime do
you think it's okay for the president to
ask his White House Counsel to lie which
look if you're just gonna go back to
where the what you're very telling me
that let me ask you the last question
that I have in 17 seconds do you think
it's okay for a president to offer
pardons to people who don't testify
against him to threaten the family of
someone who does is that okay
what when did he offer a pardon
I think you know what I'm talking about
please these
mr. attorney-general you know give us
some credit for knowing what the hell is
going on around here with you not really
to this line of questioning so listen
you've slandered this man yeah what I
sort of want to know is how do we get or
how do we get to this point thank you
very much
slander this man from top to bottom so
if you want more of this you're not
gonna get it if you don't ask him
questions you can certainly have your
opinion Thank You mr. chairman Thank You
general bar for being here today we
really appreciate your time I I want to
talk with you just a little bit about
some of your bottom line conclusions
because I think there's one that we need
to kind of circle back to a little bit
and as I've listened to a lot of the
conversation here today one of the
things we've not discussed is what seems
to be the culture at DOJ and the FBI and
I know there are a lot of good people
that work there and we're grateful for
their service but every organization has
a culture and whether it's a corporate
culture or a church or schools or
whatever and what seems to have happened
at the FBI is there is a seedy cynical
political culture within a group that
developed and these individuals
collectively seem to think that they
could work within the power of their
jobs and their roles with the federal
government there was an elitism and an
arrogance there and it speaks to a very
unhealthy work culture within that
agency and I will tell you this when I
talked to Tennesseans they talk a lot
about what they want to see with the
Department of Justice and the FBI
all of this and a restoration of trust
in integrity and accountability and
really in Tennessee they'll talk to me
about four four things they talk a lot
about health care jobs in the economy
they're going to talk about getting
federal judges confirmed and about
reining in government and holding it
accountable and there's been a lot of
hysteria this is something that grew
within the ranks of the FBI what are you
doing and what is your plan for
rebuilding that trust and integrity so
that the American people can say when
the FBI does its job when the DOJ does
its job we know that is a job done right
I don't think there is there is a bad
culture in the FBI and I don't think the
problems that manifested themselves
during the 2016 election are endemic to
the institution I think the FBI is doing
its job I mean just this recent case out
in California where they interdicted
this you know would-be bomber there they
do great work around the country every
day and it's a I agree with senator
Kennedy who said you know it's the
premier law enforcement institution in
the world I believe that and I say to
the extent there was overreach I don't
want to judge people's motives and come
to a conclusion on that but to the
extent there was overreach what we have
to be concerned about is you know a few
people at the top what get getting it
into their heads that they know better
than the American people and and that is
the problem and that is what we hope
that you are you're addressing let's go
back to this because to repeat to the
report to produce it I think that mr.
Muller assembled what would be called a
dream team 19 all-star lawyers a
Watergate prosecutor a deputy Celeste
Solicitor General a fluent Russian
speaker who clerked for two Supreme
Court justices former head of the Enron
investigative task force she
of the public corruption unit in the
Manhattan US Attorney's Office federal
prosecutors who have taken down mob
bosses the Mafia and Isis terrorists do
you consider these lawyers to be the
best and the brightest in the field
not necessarily are they the Warriors
you would want on your side in the
courtroom I mean you know there's a lot
of great lawyers in the Department of
Justice you know he assembled a very
competent team are they meticulous
investigators who will hunt down every
witness in every piece of evidence I
think they are tenacious investigators
are they devoted to finding the truth
yes are they masters at taking down
hardened criminals foreign and domestic
yes if there were evidence to warrant a
recommendation for collusion charges
against the president do you believe the
Special Counsel team would have found it
yes and if there were evidence to
warrant your recommendation for
obstruction of justice charges against
the president do you believe the Muller
team would have found it I think that
they had an exhaust they canvassed the
evidence exhaustively on they didn't
reach a decision on it but the question
just been asking raises a point I wanted
to say when senator Hirono was talking
which is it's how did we get to the
point here where the evidence is now
that the president was falsely accused
of colluding with the Russians and
accused of being treasonous and accused
of being a Russian agent and the
evidence now is that was without a basis
and two years of his administration have
been dominated by the allegations that
have now been proven false and you know
to listen to some of the rhetoric you
would think that the Muller report had
found the opposite and you know mr.
Attorney General I will tell you that is
what Tennessee and say they say how did
we get here how is there this allowance
and accepted 'no sub saying that's okay
because it's not
and people want to see government held
accountable they want agencies to act
with accountability to the American
people and they don't want to ever see
this happen again it doesn't matter if a
candidate is Democrat a Republican or an
independent they never want to see this
happen again
because they know that this was pointed
at using the power that they had to try
to tilt an election or to achieve a
different outcome and the American
people want equal justice they want
respect for the rule of law and they
want fairness from the system I have one
other question dealing with social media
Tennessee Republican Party had a ten
underscore GOP account that was set up
by the Russians
and you know either I think as we look
at social media either they were willing
to turn a blind eye and allow these
accounts to go up because they knew they
were being paid in rubles on some of
these accounts and/or if there was just
negligence so my hope is that with all
the bad actor states whether it is
Russia or Iran or North Korea or China
that you all have a game plan for
dealing with these platforms in a way
that you're going to reign demand for
the 2020 election I yield back
thank you senator Booker Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Bharat as I take a step
back at this I just really think we're
at a very sobering moment in American
history that there is a considerable
amount going along when you actually
take time and read this whole report
that shows that we're sort of at a
crossroad and I fear that we're
descending into a new normal that is
dangerous for our democracy on a number
of levels and I fear unfortunately I
hope we have a chance to discuss this
that
that you've not only put your own
credibility into question but seemed to
be giving sanction to behavior through
the language you used in that press
conference you held the language you use
in your summary that that stimulated
Muller to write such a strong rebuking
letter I fear that you are adding
normalcy to a point where we should be
sounding alarms as opposed to saying
that there's nothing to see here
and so one this 448 page report that has
a deep litany of lies and deceit and
misconduct of President on straights
instructing people to lie and be
deceitful evidence of people trying to
cover up behavior that on its face is
morally wrong whatever the legal
standard is I found it number one - by
saying that this kind of obstructive
conduct was acceptable not only
acceptable but your sentence literally
saying that the American people should
be grateful for it that is the beginning
of normalization that I want to explore
but the second thing I want to explore
and we'll explore this but I want to
make my two statements at the top one
that's problematic and and general the
second problem I have is that you seem
to be excusing a campaign that literally
had hundreds of contacts with a foreign
adversary that I think there's a
conclusion amongst on a bipartisan
conclusion that there was a failure to
even report those contacts that we
engaged in behaviors that folks knew
that that were wrong that they tried to
actively hide they seem to capitalize
seek to capitalize on this foreign
interference I mean in our country we
know it is illegal for a campaign and
wrong for a campaign to share polling
data with an American super PAC but we
have here documented a level of
coordination with a foreign adversary
sharing polling data
and and and we're seem to be and your
conduct seems to be trying to normalize
that behavior and that's why I think we
are in such a serious moment that could
that is eroding the cultures of this
democracy in the security is democracy
and so let's just get into some of this
specifically you said quote we know that
the Russian operatives who perpetrated
these schemes did not have the
cooperation of President Trump or the
Trump campaign that is something that
all Americans can and should be grateful
to have confirm the things I just
mentioned a willingness to meet with
Russian operatives in order to
capitalize on information I don't think
that's something that should be grateful
III find your choice of words alarming I
think it calls into question your
objectivity when you look at the actual
context of the report and so should the
American people really be grateful that
a candidate for president sought to
benefit from material and information
that was stolen by a foreign power in an
effort to influence an election I'm not
sure what you mean by seek to benefit
there's there's no indication that they
engaged in the can either the conspiracy
to act or that they engaged in any
action with respect to the dissemination
that was criminal well again sir you're
using the word conspiracy which is a
legal term in that press conference who
used president Trump's words obstruction
over and over again polling options a
legal term well well sir you pulled into
his words and I'm asking you
specifically I'm sorry collusion was the
word I was looking for you use the word
no collusion over and over again and and
you said the American people should be
grateful that the president sought to
benefit from material and information
but you know they did seek to benefit
from that material Donald Trump jr. in
his own email seemed to celebrate that
he might have access to information from
a foreign adversary is that correct
that's something the American people
should be waiting for apparently
according to the report he was
yeah apparently he was interested in
seeing what this Russian woman had in
the way of quote and and and did not
report it as I think everybody who's in
politics knows it's on the institution
the American people would be grateful
but that in the face of our attack on
our democracy by a foreign adversary
that the present United States made
several documented attempts to thwart an
investigation into the links between his
campaigns and Russia use that word
grateful again that the American people
should be grateful it should is that
something we should be grateful for I'm
not sure what what you're talking sir
I'm talking about the attempts that this
president made that that Muller coin
today at least ten attempts to thwart an
investigation into the links between his
campaign and Russia should we be
grateful for those attend
well-documented attempts by Muller are
you talking about the obstruction part
of the talking about the second volume
but but let me continue should the
American people be grateful that the
Trump had more than 215 documented
contacts between Russian link operatives
and then lied about them and tried to
hide them is that something the American
people should be grateful for any
president this one or any down the road
as I mentioned earlier during a campaign
foreign governments make and and and
foreign citizens frequently make a lot
of attempts to contact different
campaigns if we were right now to go and
look at for example Hillary Clinton's
campaign during the same time frame then
then you would see a lot of and and
that's I guess what I'm trying to say to
you sir is that we right now have a new
normal in our country we have a document
that shows over 200 attempt a
connections between a presidential
campaign and a foreign adversaries
sharing information that would be
illegal if you did it with a super PAC
we know that but the animation was
shared polling data was shared sir it's
in the report I can cite you the page
and I guess my point is is that your
willingness to seem to brush over
this and use words like the American
people should be grateful what's in this
report nobody should be grateful
concerted efforts for deception for
misleading inappropriate action after
inappropriate action that that is clear
and then on top of that at a time that
we all recognize that we had a foreign
power trying to undermine our election
you the chief law enforcement officer
not only undermines your own credibility
as an independent actor when there's
ongoing investigation still using the
word president's own words having it
criticized by the Muller himself but but
the challenge we now have is that we are
going into an area where you seem to not
even be willing to be in the least bit
critical in your summarizations I
believe that calls in your credibility
and again my time is up to us Thank You
mr. chairman general Barr thank you for
being here on the in the last sentence
on page one of your four-page memo it
states that the special counsel issued
more than 2,800 subpoenas executed
nearly 500 search warrants obtained more
than 230 orders for communication
records issued almost 50 orders
authorizing the use of pen registers
made 13 requests of foreign governments
for evidence and interviewed
approximately 500 people that seems like
a pretty extensive investigation to me
took about 22 months right right
and it was summarized in about a little
over four hundred page document volume 2
was just under 200 pages as I recall
I've read volume 2 word-for-word and
I've read most of a volume 1 the new
normal that seems to be created here is
even after all of this investigation and
you haven't found any conduct worthy of
indictment that you can just bounce back
for political reasons and indict
somebody that's a rhetorical statement
or question not a statement now I want
to go back to the other part that I find
interesting here the New York Times
already issued a headline that says more
pushed in letter for bar to release the
reports summary so now the the narrative
because I've had a lot of people in the
press coming out and the narrative is
well doesn't this undermine the the
Attorney General because Muller wanted
the executive summaries
now I want to go back to what you said
in your opening statement you said that
I believe using your words the the body
politic was that was unrest 'full you
got in the report you didn't get the
sixty information you had to do the
redacting you knew that was going to
take time it would have been helpful if
you had gotten that when the report was
transmitted to you and it took however
long it took you the summary you use the
analogy of announcing the verdict and
waiting for the transcript did you ever
at any point say you know what I really
want to do is issue this letter and then
let the news media play with it for
three or four weeks and then we'll get
the redacted version out that ever cross
your mind no we were pushing to get it
done as soon to get the report out as
soon as possible and at any point in
time when the president had the
opportunity to issue their own advice on
redactions or assert executive privilege
over the course of the weeks that you
were doing the review of the report did
you ever get advice from the president
or from anybody in the White House to a
certain executive privilege or to redact
any portion of the document no none
and so the narrative between the letter
and the redaction process was we're
going to get a report that's 80%
redacted now would you give me the
numbers again on the version that's
available to the leadership of Congress
the numbers again I think you said one
lesson of one person but we're skipping
over Volume one and we're spending time
on volume
- did I hear you say that the
legislative leaders have access to all
but one tenth of one percent of the
entire report approximately yes so guys
you can go out and spend this anyway you
want to but the data is there there was
no underlying crime and there was
insufficient evidence to indict the
President on obstruction of justice you
said something else it's interesting me
and the report about that we found no
evidence that was sufficient to indict
but then they went on to say nor can we
exonerate them what is a Special Counsel
in the business of exonerating a subject
of an investigation they're not they're
not so why would somebody put something
like that in the report I don't know and
so what it would
follow if that's uncommon that you would
not have actually included that in a
summary before the full context of the
report can be produced is that a fair
statement that's a fair statement but I
did put in the sentence about nod I did
put in the sentence about not
exoneration yeah I think that the thing
that frustrates me number one I should
have started by saying this the vast
majority of people in the Department of
Justice and the FBI or extraordinary
people the Chairman is right
starting with struck and page and
everybody else leading up before the
investigation I hope they're being
investigated I have a question for you
the scope of the OIG where does the do
you understand or do you know what the
scope of that report will be will it be
purely on this investigation it would
extend all other acts that may have in
some way influenced this investigation
well I don't want to be too specific
I talked to to Mike Horowitz
a few weeks ago about it and it's
focused on the FISA the basis for the
FISA and the handling of the FISA
applications but by necessity it looks
back a little bit earlier than that the
people I have helping me with my review
will be working very closely with mr.
Horowitz I want to go back again because
we have other people talking I'm sure
it's going to come up again I'm clear in
this report there was no underlying
crime is that correct
that yes that's the conclusion of the
room and there was insufficient evidence
or insufficient evidence to assert that
the president obstructed justice and a
lot of that evidence was in the public
eye because we talked about tweets and
public statements and a number of other
things that we're trying to use to
assert as evidence for obstruction of
justice it seems odd to me
that people on this committee that pound
and pound over and over again that
you're innocent improving until proven
guilty with the extent of this report
with the number of resources nearly 30
million dollars when the facts don't
lead to the outcome that you want it the
one that the marketing department wanted
to use this as a
for the next 20 months it seems odd to
me that we'd go down the path of saying
that well in spite of all the work we're
gonna indict them anyway and if we can't
indict them then we're gonna impugn your
integrity and call you a liar
I find that behavior on this committee
despicable thank you Thank You senator
Harris Thank You mr. chairman attorney
general bar has the president or anyone
at the White House ever asked or
suggested that you open an investigation
of anyone I wouldn't I wouldn't yes or
no has the President or anyone at the
White House ever asked or suggested that
you open an investigation of anyone yes
or no please sir the president or
anybody else seems you would remember
something like that and be able to tell
us yeah but I'm trying to grapple with
the word suggest I mean there have been
discussions of matters out there that
they have not asked me to open an
investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggest hinted I don't know inferred you
don't know okay in your March 24th
summary you wrote that quote after
reviewing the special counsels final
report will show that no I'm asking a
question in your March 24th summary you
wrote that quote after reviewing the
special counsels final report Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein and I have
concluded that the evidence is not
sufficient to establish that the
president committed an obstruction of
justice offense now the special counsels
investigation produced a great deal of
evidence I've led to believe it included
witnesses notes and emails witnesses
congressional testimony of witnesses
interviews which were summarized in the
FBI 302 forms former FBI director
Comey's memos and the president's public
statements my question is in reaching
your conclusion did you personally
review all of the underlying evidence no
we took and accepted mr. Rosen
no we accepted the statements in the
report as the factual record we did not
go underneath it to see whether or not
they were accurate we accepted it as
accurate and made our say you are
accepted the report as the evidence yes
you did not question or look at the
underlying evidence that supports the
conclusions in the report no did mr.
Rosenstein review the evidence that
underlines and supports the conclusions
and the report to your knowledge not to
my knowledge we accepted the statements
and the report anywhere accumulation of
the evidence is true did anyone in your
executive office review the evidence
supporting the report no no yet you
represented to the American public that
the evidence was not quote sufficient to
support an obstruction of justice the
evidence presented in the report this is
not a this is not a mysterious process
in the Department of Justice we have
Prospero's and declination memos every
day coming up and we don't go and look
at the underlying evidence we serve
would you support the characterization
of the evidence as true as the Attorney
General of the United States
you run the United States Department of
Justice if in any US Attorney's Office
around the country the head of that
office when being asked to make a
critical decision about in this case the
person who holds the highest office in
the land and whether or not that person
committed a crime would you accept them
recommending a charging decision to you
if they'd had not reviewed the evidence
well that's a question for Bob Muller
he's the US attorney he's the one who
presents the report but it was you who
made the charging decision sir you made
the decision not to charge the president
in a prospero and in the declination
memo you said it was your baby what did
you mean by that
it was my baby to look to let to decide
whether or not to disclose it to the
public and whose decision was it who had
the power to make the decision about
whether or not the evidence was
sufficient project make a determination
of whether there had been an absurd
of justice prosecution memos go up to
the supervisor in this case it was the
the Attorney General and the Deputy
Attorney General who decide on the final
decision and that is based on the memo
as presented by the US Attorney's Office
the evidence and we can move on will you
agree to consult career DOJ ethics
officials about whether your refusal
from the 14 investigations that have
been discussed by my colleagues is
necessary I don't see any basis for it I
already consulted with them and you have
consulted with them about the 14 other
investigations that about the Muller
case have you consulted with the career
DOJ ethics officials about the
appropriateness of you being involved or
recusing yourself one of the 14 other
investigations that have conflict of
interest clear what's my conflict event
I think the American public has seen
quite well that you are biased in the
situation and you've not been objective
and that would arguably be the conflict
oh you know I haven't been the only
decision-maker here now let's take the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
who was approved by this Senate 94 to 6
with specific discussion on the floor
that he would be responsible for
supervising the Russian investing I'm
glad you brought up that that's a great
start heirs experience and we had a
number of senior prosecutors in the
department involved in this process both
career and non-career yes I have another
question and I'm glad you brought that
subject up because I have a question
about that earlier today in response to
Senator Graham you said quote that you
consulted with Rosen Stein constantly
unquote with respect to the special
counsels investigation or report but
Deputy Attorney General Rosenstein is
also a key witness in the firing of FBI
director Comey did you consult with D
I'm not finished
did you consult with DOJ ethics
officials before you enlisted rod
Rosenstein to participate in a charging
decision for an investigation the
subject of which he is also
witness my understanding was that he had
been cleared already to participate in
advice so you had consulted with them
and they cleared it
no I think they cleared it when he's
when he took over the investigation did
you can I understanding I am you don't
know whether he's been cleared of a
conflict of interest he would be
participating if there was a conflict of
interest so you're saying that it did
not need to be reviewed by the career
ethics officials in your office I
believe I believe it was well I believe
it was reviewed and I and what we also
point out this seems to be a bit of a
flip flop because when the president's
observers were that you're not answering
the question directly did the ethics
officials in your office in the
Department of Justice review the
appropriateness of Rodd Rosenstein being
a part of making a charging decision on
an investigation which he is also a
witness in yeah
so as I said my understanding was he had
been cleared and he had been cleared
before I arrived in making a decision on
the Moller report yes and and the
findings of whether or not the case
would be charged on obstruction of
justice he had been cleared on that he
was he was the acting Attorney General
on the Muller investigation had he been
cleared I am by your side I am I am
informed that before I arrived he had
been cleared by the ethics officials of
what serving as acting Attorney General
on the Muller case how about making a
charging decision on obstruction of
justice what aligning offenses which
include him as a witness that's what the
acting Attorney General's job is to be a
witness and to make the decision about
being a prosecutor well no but to make
charging decisions I have nothing else
my time is right now thank you sir
let's see we got senator Cruz I'd like
to do short second rounds I've got to go
to another hearing it 2:40 we're gonna
take four votes but to my colleagues on
the other side I would like to do a very
short second round and wrap it up oh I'm
sorry senator
sir Crapo huh apologize all right Thank
You attorney general bar I know you've
gone through almost everything that
could have been asked so far today but
and I'm gonna go over a few things that
you've already talked about but I
appreciate your willingness to get into
it with me first I want to talk about
the letter of March 27th that's been
talked about a lot from mr. Miller first
could you tell me who released that
letter to the public yes I mean how did
it get released was that a decision that
you made to release that letter yeah I
think the department provided it this
morning
oh no I excuse me I mean went to the
Washington Post how did the Washington
Post get the letter I don't know that's
what I thought
so well let's talk about the letter for
a moment you indicated that I assume the
Washington Post got it from the
Department of Justice yeah well I think
I need to find that out but we can get
into that later if you're not aware then
let's move on to other aspects of the
issue you indicated that you did not
feel you needed to release as much as
mr. Miller thought you needed to release
at the outset you gave a summary of the
conclusions and he apparently wanted to
see the summaries of each section that
he had put together release correct yes
could you go over again the reason why
you responded to him when he asked you
to release portions of the report before
he released it in its entirety yes
this was on the conversation on Thursday
the day I got his letter and I said that
I didn't want to put out it was already
several days after we had received the
report and I had put out the four-page
letter on Sunday and I said I don't I
don't want to put out summaries of the
or that would trigger all kinds of
frenzy about what was said in the
summaries and then when the more
information comes out it would
recalibrate to that and I said I just
want to put it at one time everything
together and I told him that was that
was the game plan all right and and I
just think it's important to point that
out again because there's been a lot of
spin about the letter and what what what
it was that was being requested and what
your response to that was right I think
it was important to help that get out
again and get clarified the reason I
asked who released the letter is because
there have been a lot of releases of
documents from the FBI that were
basically leaks I was just curious as to
whether that letter was a leak I'm not
asking you that to go I think what
happened I mean people jump on this but
I think the fact of the mean the
information about motors concerns were
leaked and I think some news
organizations were starting to ask about
that and so then the letter had in that
context I think so there were leaks at
least about the concerns that and the
conversations that you had had yes that
gets back to the broader question of
leaks that that I want to get into now
and you've had a number of people the
Senators have asked you about the
perceived bias at the FBI I heard your
responses earlier that you believe the
culture at the FBI is strong and solid
and I agree with that I do believe
however that it's been pretty clearly
shown in a number of different ways that
there are some individuals at the FBI at
high levels who in the past few years
have not been holding up the standards
of the FBI that the American people
expect of them I'm sure you're familiar
with the report of the DOJ inspector
general Michael Horowitz where he looked
at bias in the FBI and in fact he found
it and he indicated in hearing in this
room before us that he did in fact find
that there was F bias at the FBI
and that but but he said that he wasn't
able to prove that the bias affected the
employees work product because as in
questions that I asked him he said I
found that there was clearly bias but in
order to prove whether that affected the
work output of those who were biased I
had to ask them whether it impacted and
they of course said no and I didn't have
other evidence to prove otherwise
this is gets back to a conversation you
had earlier about whether the FBI's
business or whether his business was to
prove a negative or whether it was to
find some actionable conduct my
reasoning going through this with you is
that I want to get at what we can do
well first of all whether you agree that
there is a problem of bias in the FBI in
some parts or in some individuals at the
FBI and whether you are undertaking
activities to address that you know I I
even political bias yes whether the
whether there is political bias that is
resulting in biased conduct by FBI
agents I haven't I haven't seen that
since I've been there I think that Chris
ray the new director has changed out the
people who were there before and brought
in not brought in from outside but
promoted and developed a new leadership
team that I think is doing a great job
and I think he's focused on on ensuring
that the bureau isn't biased and that
any of the problems from before or
addressed so do you believe that it's
inappropriate conduct for an FBI
employee to leak politically sensitive
information to the public for purposes
of impacting political yes discussion
yes and and I think some leaks some
leaks are for maybe for political
purposes I think probably more leaks or
because people handling a case don't
like what their superiors or
visors are doing and they and they leak
it in order to control people up the
chain and I understand you have some
investigations into that type of conduct
underway yes just another couple of
quick questions
when did the DOJ and the FBI if you know
when did the DOJ and the FBI know that
the Democratic Party paid for
Christopher Steele's
dossier which then served as the
foundation for the Carter page fire
application I don't know the answer to
that are you investigating to determine
that yes
and then lastly did the Department of
Justice the FBI and other federal
agencies engage in investigative
activities before an official
investigation was launched in July 2016
I don't know the answer to that but
that's one of the you're also
investigating on that all right thank
you very much general senator Cruz Thank
You mr. chairman general Barr thank you
for your testimony and let me start by
just saying thank you you've had an
extraordinarily successful legal career
you didn't have to take this job and you
step forward and answered the call yet
again knowing full well that you would
be subject to the kind of slanderous
treatment the Cavanaugh treatment that
we have seen of senators impugning your
integrity and I for one am grateful that
you answered that call and are leading
the Department of Justice both with
integrity and fidelity to law that is
what the nation rightly expects of our
Attorney General and I believe you are
performing that very abling I think this
hearing today has been quite revealing
to anyone watching it although perhaps
not for the reason some of the
Democratic senators intended one thing
that's revealing and the discussion and
questions that came up a word that
occurred almost none at all
is the word Russia for two and a half
years we heard
kradic senators going on and on and on
about Russia collusion
we heard journalists going on and on and
on about Russia collusion alleging among
other things some using extreme rhetoric
calling the president a traitor we heard
very little of that in this hearing
today instead the principal attack the
Democratic senators have marshaled upon
you concerns this March 27th letter from
Robert Muller and it's an attack that I
want people to understand just how
revealing it is if this is their whole
argument they ain't got nothing so their
argument as as follows let me see if I
understand it correctly you initially
when you receive the mullah report
released to Congress and the public a
four-page summary of the conclusions
then on March 27th mr. Muller asks you
to release an additional 19 pages the
introduction and summary that he had
drafted and indeed in the letter what he
says is quote I am requesting that you
provide these materials to Congress and
authorized their public release at this
time and the reason he says it is to it
is that it is that to fully capture the
context nature and substance of the
offices work in conclusion so you did
not release those 19 pages at that time
instead a couple of weeks later you
released 448 pages the entire report
which includes those 19 pages do I have
that timeline correct that's right so
their entire argument is general Barr
you suppress the 19 pages that are
entirely public that we have that we can
read that they know every word of it and
their complaint is it was delayed a few
weeks and that was because of your
decision not to release the report
piecemeal but rather to release those 19
pages along with the entire 448 pages
produced
by the special counsel yes if that is
their argument
I have to say that as an exceptionally
weak argument because if you're hiding
something I'll tell you right now
general Bart you're doing a very lousy
job of hiding it because the thing that
they're suggesting you hid you released
to Congress and the American people and
so if anyone wants to know what's in
those 19 pages that are being so
breathlessly Oh Bob Butler said release
the 19 pages you did you did it a couple
of weeks later but we can read every
word of the 19 pages along with the full
report in your judgment was the Muller
report thorough
yes did they expend enormous time energy
and resources investigating and
producing that report yes and the Muller
report concluded flat out on the
question of Russian collusion the
evidence did not support criminal
charges that's right
and indeed the Muller report if I have
the stats right was compiled by 19
lawyers who were on the team
approximately 40 FBI agents intelligence
analysts forensic accountants and
professional staff the Special Counsel
issued more than 2,800 subpoenas nearly
500 search warrants more than 230 orders
for communication records almost 50
orders authorizing the use of pen
register 13 requests to foreign
government for evidence and interviewed
approximately 500 witnesses is that
correct that's right so we have
investigated over and over and over
again and the substance of the
accusations that have been leveled at
the president for two and a half years
have magically disappeared instead the
complaint is the 19 pages that we can
all read that is entirely public could
have been released a few weeks earlier
oh the calamity let me shift to a
different topic a topic that has been
addressed already quite a bit I believe
the Department of Justice under the
Obama administration was profoundly
politicized and was weaponized to go
after political opponents of the
President
if that is the case
would you agree that politicizing the
Department of Justice and weaponizing it
to go after your political opponents is
an abuse of power
I think it's an abuse of power
regardless of who does it of course yeah
to the best of your knowledge
when did surveillance of the Trump
campaign begin the position today
appears to be that it began in July but
I do not know the answer to the question
it is an unusual thing is it not for the
Department of Justice to be
investigating a candidate for president
particularly a candidate from the
opposing party of the party in power yes
do we know if the Obama administration
investigated any other candidates
running for president I don't know do we
know if they wiretapped well any other I
guess they were investigating Hillary
Clinton for the the email the email do
we know if there were wiretaps I don't
know do we know if there were efforts to
set investigators in wearing a wire
I don't know so general Barr I would
urge you have had remarkable
transparency you promised this committee
you would with regard to the Muller
report you promised this committee and
the American people you would release
the Muller report publicly you have
released the report anyone can read it
it's right here I appreciate that
transparency I would ask you to bring
the same transparency to this line of
questioning about whether whether and
the extent to which the previous
administration politicized the
Department of Justice targeted their
political rivals and use law enforcement
and intelligence assets to surveil them
improperly thank you so that's the end
of the first round we have votes I think
at 3:00 I think there for votes but what
I'd like to do is just can you go for a
few more minutes here you're okay all
right Senator Leahy you're next would be
three minutes second rounds noted she
felt the FBI v Darryl
do the Adhan investigate after learn
maestro yeah not the Trump
administration by Australia the Trump
campaign new Russia has stolen
democratic emails before the victimís do
never told the Russians could exist as a
campaign with that with the it's torn
emails the FBI was right to look into it
that resolved course than 37 indictments
well let me ask you mr. Barr and your
viceroy for letter you claimed that the
lack of evidence of that underlying
crime bears them whether the president
had the requisite intent to commit
obstruction of justice
well there are numerous reasons why
somebody might interfere with
investigations most critically any
interference may prevent the discovery
of an underlying crime this all
interfering you might not know that as a
crime but the Special Counsel did
uncover evidence of underlying crimes
here including one that directly
implicated the president and then we
learned due to the special counsels
investigation that Donald Trump is known
as individual one in the Southern
District of New York directing hush
payments as part of a criminal scheme to
violate campaign finance laws that
matter was discovered by the special
counsel referred to the Southern
District in New York is that correct yes
thank you and we have more report
references a dozen ongoing
investigations stemming from the special
counsels investigation you commit that
you will not interfere with those
investigations so you say you commit the
jewel not interfere with the dozen
ongoing investigations I I will
supervise those investigations as
Attorney General
we let them reach natural conclusions
without interference from the white
house let me put it that way then yes
yeah as I said when I was up for
confirmation part of my responsibility
is to make sure there is no political
interference and cases
well you testified a number of things
and that's why I'm double checking you
the Appropriations Committee I asked you
whether mr. mauler expressed any
expectation or interest and leaving the
instruction decision to Congress you
testified he didn't say that to you yeah
that's what you said he did didn't say
that to me right but then he has
numerous references in his report to
Congress playing a role in deciding
whether the president committed
obstruction of justice so I know you
testify many times but I was not correct
that's not correct I think it is correct
I mean I don't he has not said that he
conducted the investigation order to
turn it over to Congress that would be
very inappropriate that's not what the
Justice Department numerous references
report to Congress playing a role in the
volume 2 page 8 includes in the Congress
may apply the instruction allows the
president scrubbed exercise of powers of
office the courts with our
constitutional system of justice I don't
think Bob Bob Muller was suggesting that
that the next step here was for him to
turn this stuff over FERC to Congress to
act upon that's not why we conduct grand
jury investigations and president Trump
I am going to my earlier statement never
allowed anybody to interview him
directly under oath is that correct I
think that's correct even though he said
he's ready to testify thank you well
Herman could I sure a point a point you
raised about the absence of a underlying
crime
one point I was trying to make earlier
is the absence of an underlying crime
doesn't necessarily mean that there were
that there would be other motives for
obstruction although it gets a little
bit harder to prove and more speculative
as to what those motives might be but
the point I was trying to make earlier
is that in this situation of the
president who has constitutional
authority to supervise proceedings if in
fact a proceeding was not well-founded
if it was a groundless proceeding if it
was based on false allegations the
president does not have to sit there
constitutionally and allow it to run its
course the president could terminate
that proceeding and it would not be a
corrupt intent because he was being
falsely accused and he would be worried
about the impact on his administration
that's important because most of the
obstruction claims that are being made
here or episodes do involve the exercise
of the president's constitutional
authority and we now know that he was
being falsely accused general more I
have two questions if you don't mind the
multi-purpose general bar I have two
questions
the model report describes the reasons
why the FBI opened a counterintelligence
investigation in July 2016 into Russian
election interference there have been
many references to why they would do
such a thing by that date the Democratic
National Committee server had been
hacked and Russians had been deemed
responsible some of the stolen emails
had been released by WikiLeaks a foreign
government the Australian government had
told our FBI the Trump foreign policy
age George papadopolis said he'd been
contacted by a person on Russia's behalf
offering to assist the Trump campaign by
releasing information damaging to
Hillary Clinton that was all in the
molar report do you believe that it was
an appropriate predicate for opening a
counterintelligence investigation
to determine whether Russia had targeted
people in the Trump campaign to offer
hacked information that might impact a
presidential election I'd have to see
exactly what the report was from downer
the Australian downer and exactly what
he quoted Papadopoulos is saying but
from what you just read I'm not sure
what the correlation was between the
Russians having dirt and jumping to the
conclusion that that suggested
foreknowledge of the hacking
according to mr. Muller and his report
this involvement of Trump foreign policy
aide George papadopolis had something to
do with their conclusion I'd like to ask
you a separate issue it's been reported
that on April 16th you received a waiver
to participate in the investigation and
litigation of the so-called 1mdb matter
this is an investigation into a
Malaysian company from alleged money
laundering according to news reports as
part of this investigation the US
Attorney's Office for the Eastern
District of New York is investigating
whether a Malaysian national illegally
donated to the Trump inaugural committee
with money taken from 1mdb you sought a
waiver to participate in this matter
even though your former law firm
Kirkland and Ellis represents an entity
involved in the investigation namely
Goldman Sachs how many waivers have you
received to allow you to participate in
matters or investigations involving
Trump businesses the Trump campaign or
the Trump inaugural committee none you
did seek waiver in this case I actually
the impetus as I recall and people
should jump me if I'm wrong but it
didn't come from me I was asked to seek
a waiver in this case do you see the
problem if the issue is whether or not a
money laundering operation Malaysia
isn't sending money to the Trump
inaugural committee that is Attorney
General of the United States you may not
want to involve yourself in this well no
I don't I don't because I was not
involved with the inaugural why would
you seek a waiver then to participate in
this the waiver was I guess the conflict
that was not because of any relationship
I had to the inaugural committee which I
didn't know it's to Goldman Sachs you'd
form a claim I would
Kirkland Ellis the law firm right and
their client Goldman Sachs I just don't
understand why you would touch that hot
stove that's a bit you sought the waiver
that's why I'm asking the question the
attorney at the Criminal Division axe
actually asked me to get a waiver
because of the importance of this
investigation overall I was requested by
the Criminal Division I didn't seek it
impetus did not come from me and who
would that be
that made their recommendation to you
yeah I am told it was the Criminal
Division mr. Benge Kowski yeah he was
the head of the Criminal Division but
before apparently they discussed it with
the career ethics official and they made
the recommendation thank you senator
Whitehouse missed a couple of timing
questions you said that on March 5th mr.
Muller came to you and said that he was
going to not make a decision on
obstruction leave that to you he didn't
he didn't say he was leaving it to me
that he was not gonna make an
obstruction on March 24th you set up a
letter describing your decision
somewhere between March 5th and March
24th you made that decision when was
that we started talking about it on
March 5th and there had already been a
lot of discussions prior to March 5th
involving the deputy the principal
associate deputy in the office of legal
counsel that had dealings with the
special counsels office so they had
knowledge of a number of the episodes
and some of the thinking of the special
counsels office so right after March 5th
we started discussing what the
implications of this were and how we
would how we and you made the decision
when I probably on Sunday the
fourth that's the day the letter came
out yes we made the decision and make
the decision until the letter came out
told somebody how to write the letter
you couldn't when did you actually
decide that there was no obstruction the
24th okay when did you get the first
draft of the malla report the first it
wasn't a draft we got the final the
first version of it that you saw well
the only version of it I saw okay the
only version for you sir when you do
first 22nd the 22nd now you told senator
Harris that you made your decision on
the obstruction charge UN Rosenstein
based on the Muller report do I
correctly infer that you made that
decision then between the 22nd and the
24th well we had had a lot of
discussions about it but for the 22nd
but the final decision was made on the
24th and you didn't yet more the 22nd we
had more than two and a half days to
consider this OLC had already done a lot
of a lot of thinking about some of these
issues even before the time we got the
report and even before March of F they
had been in regular contact the
department had been in regular contact
with Muller's people and understood olc
was looking into the Muller
investigation while it was going on and
winning of the evidence that they were
gathering on obstruction before you saw
them I understand you know I wasn't
there okay
but my understanding is that the deputy
and the we call the paytag the principal
associate deputy were in regular contact
with the Muellers team and we're getting
briefings on evidence and some of their
thinking and some of the issues if they
know enough to know Noel C was brought
into some of those discussions did they
know enough to know it might be need to
be redacted before they saw the 3:22 no
we do the problem we had is we could not
identify the 6e material
when when the report came over we needed
the help of Bob Muller's team to do that
and lastly can you assure me that
nothing related to obstruction or the
Muller report was discussed at your
office of legal counsel brown bag lunch
on June 27th nothing bad what nothing
about the obstruction issue and nothing
about the Muller report itself was
discussed when you had a brown bag lunch
on June 27th with OLC yeah we didn't
discuss anything having to do with a
Muller report or Muller's eventual
position on a discuss your obstruction
memo and I forgot if it was then but I
think I've previously said that I
mentioned that I had a memo and and was
sending it to you you have not yet said
that it was mentioned at this olc though
I I don't I don't think it was not at
the brown bag lunch now my time is up
okay we're the vote is started we're
gonna split the time between senator
Klobuchar and senator Blumenthal will
try to go they won't hold a vote open
too long but let's start with senator
Klobuchar and see if we can do this
Thank You mr. Attorney General on April
27th president Trump stated Muller I
assume for 35 million dollars he checked
my taxes and he checked my financials
is that accurate did the special counsel
review the president's taxes and the
Trump organization's financial
statements I don't know can you find out
if
you
and then obviously we would want to see
them as underlying information during my
earlier questions we went through a
number of actions by the president that
the special counsel looked into my point
was that we should be looking into the
totality of the evidence and the pattern
that the report develops on page 13 of
volume 2 the Special Counsel instructs
that we do something similar the report
says and this is a quote circumstantial
evidence that illuminates intent may
include a pattern of potentially
obstructive acts on this point the
report cites three u.s. cases US v
Franken Hauser or Frank Houser US v
Arnold and US v sin Tolo do you agree
that obstruction law allows for intent
to be informed by a pattern of
potentially obstructive acts well intend
eventually has to be as established by
proof beyond a reasonable doubt
obviously some inferences can be drawn
from circumstantial evidence that can
contribute to an overall determination
of proof beyond a reasonable doubt but
that's one of the problems with this
whole approach that's suggested in the
the special counsels report which is it
is trying to determine the subjective
intent of a facially lawful act and it
permits a lot of selectivity on the part
of the prosecutors and an end and it's
been shot down in a number of other
contexts so one of the reasons that we
are very skeptical of this approach is
that you and director Muller or you the
Justice Justice Department is that in
this kind of situation we have a
facially innocent act and faith you know
it's authorized by the Constitution
I just it's hard to it's hard to
establish beyond a reasonable doubt that
it's corrupt okay I just want to get in
just a few more questions like Senator
Whitehouse did at your confirmation
hearing you testified that in the
absence of a violation of a statute the
president would be accountable
politically for abusing the pardon power
how do you reconcile your suggestion
that political accountability is
available when the administration is
refusing to comply with subpoenas and
asserting executive privilege to stand
in the way of that very accountability
as to a pardon no this was about in your
confirmation hearing you said in the
absence of a violation of a statute the
president would be quote accountable
politically end quote for abusing the
pardon power if he did but your question
really is abusing any power not just the
pardon power is that what you're saying
well president it's hard to evaluate
that residents have been held
accountable before and and as have other
office holders okay last question are
the president's actions detailed in this
report consistent with his oath of
office and the requirement in the
Constitution that he take care that the
laws be faithfully executed is what
consistent with that I said are the
president's actions detailed in the
report consistent with his oath of
office and the requirement in the
Constitution that he take care that the
laws be faithfully executed well the the
evidence in the report is conflicting
and and there's different evidence and
they don't they don't come to a
determination as to how they're coming
down on it and so you made that decision
yes and and as you know if it's all
right we got okay
two minutes left senator Blumenthal
Thank You mr. chairman
Attorney General bar I wonder if you
could tell us about the conversation
between yourself and Bob Muller shortly
after your summary was issued
he called you no I called him what
prompted you to call him the letter Y or
a letter or his like his letter so you
called him yeah
and how long did the conversation last I
don't know maybe 10 15 minutes there
were multiple witnesses in the room it
was on a speaker phone who was in the
room among others the deputy attorney
general was in the room anyone else yeah
several other people who had been
working on the project members of your
staff yes and and the deputy staff and
as best you can recall in the language
that was used who who said what to whom
I said Bob what's with the letter you
know I just pick up the phone and call
me if there's an issue and he said that
they were concerned about the way the
media was playing this and felt that it
was important to get out the summaries
which they felt would put their work in
proper context and avoid some of the
confusion that was emerging and I asked
him if he felt that my letter was
misleading or inaccurate and he said no
that the press he felt that the press
coverage was and it was and that a
completer a more complete picture of his
thoughts in the context and so forth
would would deal with that and I
suggested that I would rather just get
the whole report out than just putting
out stuff seriatim and and piecemeal and
but I said I would think about it some
more and the next day I put out a letter
that made it clear that no one should
read the March 24th letter as a summary
of the
overall report and that a full account
of Bob's Muller's thinking was going to
be in the report and everyone could
would have access to but there's nothing
in Robert Miller's letter to you about
the press his complaint to you is about
your characterization of the report
correct well the letter speaks for
itself it does and in fact in response
to your question why not just pick up
the phone this letter was an
extraordinary act a career prosecutor
rebuking the Attorney General of the
United States memorializing in writing
right I know of no other instance of
that happening you all right I don't
consider Bob at this stage a career
prosecutor he's had a career as a
prosecutor well he's a very eminent I
was the head of the FBI for 12 years
he's a career he's had a he's a law
enforcement professional right yeah I
know of no other instance of but he was
also political appointee and he was a
political appointee with me at the
Department of Justice I don't you know
if the letters a bit snitty and I think
it was probably written by one of his
staff people did you make a Memorandum
of your conversation huh did you make a
memory I did what did anyone else well
um did anyone either you or anyone on
your staff memorialize your conversation
with Robert Muller yes who did that
there were notes taken of the call may
we have those notes no why not why
should you have them I'll tell you we
got to end this but I'm gonna write a
letter to mr. Muller and I'm gonna ask
him is there anything you said about
that conversation he disagrees with and
if there is he and come and tell us
right so the hearing is now over if I
don't let me go I promise you that if
there's any mr. Muller we'll have a
chance to make sure that the
conversation relay by attorney
bars accurate and I'm gonna give him a
chance to correct anything you said that
he finds misleading or inaccurate and
that will be it five seconds Attorney
General bar I just want to thank you for
your service to our country and
especially today I want to thank you for
your civility and your composure amidst
what has been a needlessly an unfairly
hostile environment your professionalism
has been remarkable I'm grateful thank
you well my point of view is pretty
interesting and it got off in a ditch
every now and then but generally
speaking the committee did pretty good
and this is what democracy is all about
thank you for being our Attorney General
thank you mister